your good attitude will help with the
horror to come
[Music]
you know doing a revisit on a show like
doctor who
you may not think this but the ones that
i get the most
nervous about doing a re-watch on are
the episodes that i
love because you get
worried that going back knowing what's
going to happen
not getting as swept up in it in the
moment
and turning a more critical eye to it
you're gonna start to
spot things that you missed before
or things that now that you have more
time to think about maybe don't work as
well as they did
or maybe you just had forgotten certain
cracks in the thing now if you're very
lucky
not only will that not happen but you'll
discover whole new reasons to love the
thing
i i was not very lucky
with the world enough in time and i need
to put
so much emphasis on this right now it
is really good i need to stress that up
front
but the thing is i know it's really good
you know it's really good but my brain
zeroed in on stuff that i'm like that's
not
quite landing
this time and unfortunately
that's probably gonna take up the bulk
of this review
so fair warning as far as that goes
i don't think i'm going to be ripping it
apart because again
it's still really good it's just not as
good
as i remember it being
so why don't we start with some of those
good points
missy her stepping out
of the tardis hello
i'm doctor who these are my disposables
exposition and comic relief and i
actually i had
completely missed the line before when
nardole says well no
functions darling those are genders like
that
i got a huge kick out of that that was
great because actually
as far as at the very least modern
doctor who goes uh
yeah that's been true if there's been
a male and a female companion the female
companion is there for the exposition
and the male
companions there for comic relief what
do you think was going on with amy and
rory
or rose and mickey for that matter
so that that was a line that was great
and i hadn't caught before
i liked the whole idea of missy
trying to be like the doctor and the
doctor using it as a test for are you
actually going to be getting better
i'm going to put you in the field and
see how you perform so that it's not
just you
saying it and i love that
as a premise the whole idea of the ship
this
massive 400 mile long ship
that is trying to get away from a black
hole but because of how long the ship is
and because
of the weirdness that goes on with black
holes and gravity and how gravity
can impact basically everything
including time
i don't know how uh scientifically sound
this is but like
it was a really neat idea and i love it
i love the idea that the time
at the front end passes way way way way
slower than down at the bottom so even
though the doctor is not really wasting
time he's moving as quick as he can
bill's down there for years
and that is a really
neat idea and a really tragic idea
knowing how long she waited for him
while simultaneously knowing that he got
there as quickly as he could
it's yeah that's a lot
and then there's the cybermen now this
obviously borrows
a great deal from spare parts which is a
big finish
audiobook that i've actually done a
review for before
and is also really good and it delves
into the origins of the audacity and
cybermen and i love
so many little touches that emphasize
how
horrifying this is and that they were
able to take
the classic honestly very low budget
look of the original cybermen and make
it truly
horrific again that something is basic
is just
basic it's like a stalking over their
heads but it makes it
terrifying and this the
god the whole thing when bill goes into
this room
of all these people just hooked up to
ivs and sitting there
one of them just hitting this key pain
pain and a nurse comes in and adjusts
the dial and he stops saying it
and you think you assume oh she adjusted
medications
she even actually like there isn't that
better but then when you realize all she
did was
turn down the volume so yeah it's better
it's better for her because she doesn't
have to hear about it
but also even though like we kind of get
this surgeon character who seems to be
orchestrating things a bit
this doesn't make the mistake that uh
age of steel uh rise of the cybermen did
back in series two which is to give
the creation of the cyberman over to one
singular
person because then it's basically just
recreating diverse in the dollars
whereas here
the emphasis is on this population is
sick
this population is dying this population
is
running out of options for how to
survive
and they're at a point where they know
how they can continue to live
but it will not be a pleasant existence
and the fact that the headpiece
it said flat out this won't stop you
feeling pain
it will stop you caring about it ah
that is horrifying
and it is brilliantly
executed at every step of the way
and honestly how good that is
is probably what either overrode my
memory for some of the stuff i'm about
to start
complaining about a little bit or had
made me not notice it in the first place
because
ah
all that having been said
there are some things that i noticed
this time or that didn't work for me
this time
the first is that honestly this episode
is two stories forced to share space
that thankfully aren't
clashing with each other but aren't
really properly complementing each other
either and i come back to something that
i actually said
either one or two videos ago that this
series really
is one episode short because
we needed an episode that was just
the doctor monitoring missy
but it's forced to share space with what
happens with bill
and missy's whole thing with dealing
with the master now here's what i'll say
about john simmons master i'll say a
couple of things
because he's a little mixed for me for a
couple of reasons
not all bad not all good here's the
first thing
i'm pretty sure that i said in my
original review of this
link there why not that i wasn't
entirely sure if he was
necessary to be here
uh the thing is though he is but he's
only necessary to
one of the two stories happening he does
need to be here
for missy's story to really
emphasize where she comes from
what she has been solidifying the story
of her
trying to be better so the presence of
the master totally works for her
story the thing is though he only gets
revealed as the master at the very end
which means for most of this
he's popping around as a completely
different
character who i like i actually like mr
razor a lot
but internally within bill's story it
doesn't matter that mr razer is really
the master
it's just there to establish that he's
been here the whole time but
as far as what he does the way that he
characterized his fake identity is 100
consistent from start to finish the fact
that he was really somebody else
has no impact you can remove that twist
and his time
as mr razor and the way that bill
interacts with him and the way that he
contributes to her story is completely
unchanged without that twist
so the master needs to be here for
missy's story
but in order to have oh he was here the
whole time we have this
twist of mr razor who is a great
character and who honestly first time i
watched this i didn't even realize it
was john simm i didn't recognize him so
props to him for that and on the makeup
but
it kind of exemplifies the two halves
not quite being a happy marriage
again not clashing with each other but
not totally
gelling either so like
i also found myself wondering why
now some of this might get addressed in
the next episode i'm going to keep an
eye out for it
but as of right now i have a lot of
questions of
why he does the whole mr razor
thing now there were a number of
questions i had
one of which gets a tossed off in my
opinion kind of flimsy answer that
actually brings up other questions
but my questions about this is why is he
on this ship in the first place
when did he get here what is his
goal in all of this did he know
the master was showing up
and why did he spend years pretending to
be somebody else in front of somebody
who has never met him before and doesn't
know who he is
now that last one does kind of get
answered because
the master says you know i have to um
pretend to be somebody else because uh
you know i
if you've been their prime minister so
that still brings up questions of
how did he figure out exactly when and
where
bill came from if he didn't have the
ability to ask her anything because
he's in the razor persona as soon as she
wakes up and he seems to be established
as
that and obviously he doesn't have to
disguise himself for the montages but he
does kind of for bill because bill might
recognize
that prime minister we had one time but
it brings up the questions of how the
heck he knows he has to disguise himself
from her because
how does he know when and where she's
from
that's okay so that's kind of dealt with
but
why is he here what brought him
here and it's not to connect with missy
we know that because he says that he
didn't recognize
and realize who she was at first so he's
not
here intentionally to run into her
so what's he doing here
and is the fact that the doctor happened
to show up an
absolute blisteringly bizarre
coincidence
cause that's uh that is a
big big coincidence that they just
happen to run into each other especially
when
i don't even know what the master's plan
is again
some of those questions may get
addressed in the next one i will keep an
eye out for that
but self-contained within within this
episode
that revelation just brought up a whole
bunch of questions that i'm like
i don't know about that some other
things that don't work um
honestly screw this cold open it's a
cold open that means nothing until we
get to the end of the next episode
and i hate flash forward
cold opens and teasers like this anyway
i really i have a really hard time
thinking of any story that benefits
from giving us a look at what happens
way later in the story
like i i'm i'm here for the story don't
jump ahead
trying i don't as a hook-in i guess
like but uh the co the cold opens
garbage
a couple of odd things that go on with
bill first of all she's a really good
vehicle
for her eyes on the mondassians
and watching everything
fall apart around her so she's
really good for that i'm a little bit
thrown off at
how antsy and nervous she is around
missy
because honestly the degree to which she
seems to be like she scares me are you
sure this is a good idea
like we really shouldn't be doing this
would be way more justified if she'd
actually had
time with missy prior to this but she
really
didn't like she's no doubt heard about
missy from the doctor and i'm sure from
nardole and like that justifies some of
it
but the degree to which she is like this
is a terrible idea
feels like the kind of um
conviction that should be coming from
somebody who
absolutely does know who this is and has
personal experience with them and she
just
doesn't honestly it's the kind of um
response that would have worked much
better coming from clara because clara
had direct experience with missy
and bill doesn't but other side um not
specifically that but to bill
i really love that in the beginning she
owns up to being the human
because while she may be expecting the
doctor to keep her safe
at that point it's very clear that this
guy wants to kill whoever's the human
and she still says it's me i'm the human
which speaks a lot to who bill is and is
one more reason why
i really love her as a character so that
was a good moment
and so ultimately i i do want to come
back and stress this episode
is good i think the problem is
because we only have 12 episodes instead
of
the old 13 that means that
what should have been more or less two
episodes
missy and the master and the cybermen
they're forced to share space now this
story is majority
cybermen but it does all the groundwork
needed to set up missing the master
which is going to be way more important
next time and to my memory the cybermen
stuff
aside from just bill herself kind of
gets sidelined
as a result so you have these two
stories
and they're just forced to share space
in there and they're crowding each other
a little bit and they're both
really good stories and because it's
over two episodes like
one is bleeding a little into the other
on both ends but
they're not kneecapping each other it
just isn't as
seamless like in the seems r there
really needed to be
another episode like honestly what
probably should have happened was
we start off with missy dedicate way
more time to the idea of missy
kind of leading this mission lead into
bill
um getting killed and captured have a
whole
missing middle episode that is focused
almost entirely on what happens to bill
and then pick it up in the third one
uh with dealing with the ramifications
of bill and then
tying off missy and the master but we're
missing that middle
one and the the way to marry it all
together
is not ideal and it's not perfect but
man what works in here
really really works still
i just found more problems which is
always frustrating
but that's world enough in time you
re-watched it lately what you think
about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it
like share subscribe i have a patreon
there may be a link more likely you'll
have to go down to the description
because
youtube's busted lately but um there's
also youtube memberships and there are
benefits for every tier of support
on both the patreon and the youtube
membership so
check that out it's my living it's what
enables me to eat and keeps this whole
operation
up and running but even if you can't
like share subscribe helps me out too
but no pressure on that either because
at the end of the day
you are the council and i am only
running the meetings
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye